hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for some
long awaited my hero academia talk which
comes about because I finally got the
chance to see heroes rising and what's
going to follow is a spoiler filled
review and general discussion but
firstly just some context so that you
know where I'm coming at this from I
have a very let's say on-and-off
relationship with my hero academia where
I do truly love the series and it never
fails to entertain me as well as hit
some very core emotional resonance but
for whatever reason I always struggle to
retain my interest in it during the long
term and I usually pick it up again
coinciding with each anime season so I
am up to date with the anime as it
stands at the time of this recording and
determines of the manga if I recall
correctly I'm actually a bit beyond that
although I am planning on catching up
imminently and then perhaps making some
my hero academia videos for this channel
if people are interested and you know if
you are please do let me know in the
comments actually you know what we can
probably call this a bit of a test video
to determine the appetite for my hero
academia stuff don't forget to like this
video either if that's the thing you
want but as for the film I was lucky
enough to see this in a cinema which is
an experience that I would highly
recommend actually probably not so much
in our current climate stay at home and
be safe everyone however seeing this on
a big screen was quite the treat
especially in regards to the final fight
which was just oh well and we'll get to
that for sure to start with though I
thought this feature had a very clever
premise in regards to isolating class
1-a from the rest of society because my
hero academia can run into some big
problems in regards to finding excuses
for our students to face off against
villains because that almost always
makes more sense to call for help from a
pro hero so that whole idea was handled
wonderfully here the class are cut off
from great society and they have been
forced to act in a most dire situation
it's also a wonderfully simple vermis
which i think is very necessary for a
film that is just over a hundred minutes
long you really don't want to get too
complicated here especially with the
absurd quantity of characters that you
need to deal with and speaking of I feel
like I always underestimate the size of
class 1a in my head because really it's
such a massive amount of characters and
to the credit of heroes rising each and
every one of them gets a pretty decent
amount of focus and screen time to do
their own thing classic film study would
teach us that a story like this simply
should not be possible due to needing to
function with you know 20 protagonists
as well as not just one but two groups
of villains and an entire town to
develop as well so I think that
characters were handled here about as
well as there could be like no matter
who your favorite member of class 1a is
I think you would be very satisfied with
their involvement in the film
and there are even a few really fun
highlights the one that surprised me the
most being a Yama so what I am currently
a Yama hasn't done a whole lot so it was
really nice to see him shine in this
film with such a devastating naval laser
blast and just generally being pushed to
a limit that I've not seen him reach so
good on him he felt well and truly
involved as a member of the class which
is exactly what I want from him we were
also given a very standard amount of
Todoroki which I always appreciate
because I find his powers to be some of
the craziest crap that this series has
to offer and along the same lines there
was also some very nice time with Tokyo
Yami who has always been one of my
personal favorite members of class 1-a
and anytime we get to see dark shadow go
berserk well count me in with all this
said the heart of the film as expected
from the trailer and I guess the series
in general comes from the characters of
ISA ku and bak ago and their volatile
yet increasingly cordial dynamic this
partnership is one for the ages though
and this film gave me exactly what I was
looking for and you know even a little
bit more in that regard and I guess I
should probably get this out of the way
now but my god that final fight is quite
possibly one of the most beautiful
scenes that I have ever seen put on
screen although I will question the
decision to all of a sudden have user Co
embargo assume the roles of Saiyan
warriors with the heavily dragon bull
evocative hair but I think that's the
only thing that struck me is a little
bit off everything else was pretty much
pure perfection especially the choice of
music it was this soft emotional track
with female vocals that if you had heard
out of context you would likely never
imagined that it would synergize so well
with a spectacle action piece where
you've got apocalyptic weather
explosions mass destruction and just a
cyclone of action going on everywhere
but it works brilliantly and I believe
what was actually used in the series as
well during the overhaul battle where it
worked pretty damn incredibly as well
but in my opinion the film definitely
has superior use of this song actually
gives me some demons SIA episode 19 kind
of vibes which implemented a similar
strategy to equal if not greater effect
and I think that anime companies have
stumbled upon a bit of a goldmine here
where they've realized that soft music
only goes to highlight the action
further through its juxtaposition rather
than having some sort of super energetic
track competing with the visuals on
screen and I will also say that I love
the decision to remove the sound
entirely for a huge chunk of the final
clash and just have that brilliant track
playing which I did look up actually in
its cold might plus you buy composer
Yuki Hayashi so phenomenal work there by
the composer and equally a stunning work
was put in by the director and the
animation team this clash is really just
one of those moments that is going to
stay with me for an awfully long time
and this film was worth it
just to see that they also really
enjoyed the idea that azúcar was forced
into a situation where he had to face
the reality of giving up his dream of
being a hero when you think about it
it's all for such a simple reason as
well music who was willing to part with
everything that he had worked for just
to save the quirk of one count'em one
young boy and I mean yeah there was
obviously a greater threat at hand in
nine who would become an exceptional
threat wit said quirk but still it's
classic Deku and I love him for it and
seeing him doing that in fact not only
that but seeing ba cuoco actually accept
the quirk for the sake of both of them
invoking one for all to secure their
victory was incredibly powerful stuff he
reminds me of one of the Dragon Ball
movies fusion reborn you know the one
lynching ember we're go coup and Vegeta
have this moment of understanding and
decide to fuse together this moment in
hero's rising obviously surpassed that
in every way shape and form and it had a
lot more meaning attached to it because
this was easy kuru link wishing
everything which while I did feel that
pretty hard there was an undeniable
voice in the back of my head saying well
this is um this is going to need to be
fixed and easy Buu was going to need to
end up with one fall again and in my
mind that likely scenario was going to
be the BOK ago we just passed the quirk
back to he's a girl with this salty you
know like damn Deku I didn't want you a
stupid quirk anyway I want to beat you
on my own terms Rara and in fact come to
think of it I don't actually know if
one-for-all can be passed back to a
previous user if that's been answered
anywhere and I've either forgotten about
it or just haven't reached it yet then
please do let me know because I'm
genuinely interested now I guess part of
me wants to believe that once you've
passed it on you can't reclaim it
otherwise what's to stop like rampant
quark passing I mean why not just pass
it to five people in quick succession
and then fight with five one for all
in any case I'm getting way off topic
here what I was trying to get to is that
my least favorite part of the film where
after the brilliantly done high-stakes
emotional matchup we're left in this
place where everything needs to be put
back to the status quo and I really
hated the explanation of how that
happened you know the whole easy coup
still has his quirk because miracle
predecessors and stuff and I'm not
saying that it doesn't make sense it
does because my hero academia pulls that
kind of crap in the actual series as
well but it just feels like such a lazy
way of restoring the status quo like a
true deus ex machina that pops up out of
nowhere
and make sure that everything is okay I
think it could have been done infinitely
better like my suggestion about Bach ago
just giving it back in his own dignified
way and if there is a problem in that
you can't have
continuity bark ago remember that he
used one for all then just have it erase
his memory after he gives the cork back
if he can give it back on I'm actually
assuming a lot here any case my point is
that it was a clumsy ending to an
otherwise superbly structure conflict
and just while we're on things I didn't
like because I can be a hypocritical
prick let's talk about the villains
specifically our head honcho 9 I really
don't care for this character at all and
I think that he was probably the weakest
part of the film which is a big problem
because he's very much the one who
instigates all of the major action and
if I had to sum up why I didn't really
care for him I'd say it was because he
was a mostly apathetic blank slate with
a quick gimmick that we've already
explored a multitude of times already in
the series being quick theft and holding
multiple quirks and top it all off his
design was it wasn't bad but it was
standard at best it was nothing special
so there was nothing really to you know
latch on to oh and to add on to that he
has the archetypal bad guy motivation
which I refer to as the utopia go you
know bad guy who wants to change the
world and reshape it in his own image
and some villains do this better than
others not this one though because 9s
reason for doing so was just because
power and stuff and it's just really
boring there's actually nothing that I
find interesting about 9 not even the
quirks he uses because none of them get
used in a particularly creative way I
mean oh he fires lasers and puts up
barriers and dragons and I just don't
understand how all of that can be made
so boring but hey he accomplished it and
in general he lacks a lot of the
subtlety and thorough exploration that
actual my hero academia villains have
which is such a key aspect of making
this series interesting a series like my
hero academia lives and dies on it's
villains because heroes alone are not
enough and for the most part my hero I
could Demian does a great job with
figures like stained shigaraki and in
fact pretty much the entire league of
villains and even guys like gentle
criminal 9 on the other hand is a reject
he is a villain who serves a technical
purpose and his motivation isn't export
anywhere near enough to remember that
this guy even existed the moment after I
pushed the publish button for this video
his lackeys weren't too bad though
especially camara who probably got the
most development out of all of them and
was the only one that I ended up feeling
anything for by the end of the film and
you know a lot of this might just be the
general limits of making an anime film
there's no time to really craft a
product that can in any way stand up to
the actual series but that doesn't mean
that it is impossible they feel like
you're as rising probably could have
spent a bit less time portraying
and just given a few much-needed minutes
to nine because he is homing the story
and it would have made the final
conflict all that more epic if we'd
actually had a stake in this character
as well still as much as I've ranted
there this is a minor issue to me it's
an anime film I didn't go into it
expecting the villains to have
incredible depth and in the end I do
have to admit that nine served his
purpose he provided a threat that
required class 1-a to come together and
use everything they've learned thus far
to overcome him and that rather simply
is the appeal of heroes rising we are
here to see our protagonist kick some
ass and continue their journeys to
become professional heroes and that's
exactly what the film delivers so as
much as there were aspects that I wish
could have been better to say that I
didn't get exactly what I wanted out of
this film would be an outright lie it
was an incredibly fun experience as my
hero academia tends to be and highly
recommend it if you're a fan of the
series although I would say don't expect
anything you know groundbreaking you're
just going to be served more of what you
already love with a side dish of Bach
ago being infused with one for all and
you know what that actually sounds like
a pretty damn fine value proposition to
me but what did you guys think of the
film please do feel free to leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
come and join the fun on my disco server
and if you came for some more anime
content and feel free to check out my
other videos and even subscribe to the
channel if you'd like to see more of
that my hero academia fantasticness but
for now this has been the new old review
and I'll see you next time